what are ghosts oh I have theories have
we not talked about this cuz I talked
about I don't know how to talk about
your theory my theories on ghosts yeah I
think I have not talked about I am smart
and I am right is that what they're
saying here no I don't know because that
would be really cool I do like I do like
your theory it's pretty all right so
let's uh let's let's let's read the
story from live science are ghosts real
evidence has not materialized stats Q if
you believe in ghosts you're not alone
cultures all around the world believe in
spirits that survived death to live in
another realm
in fact ghosts are among the most widely
believed of paranormal phenomenon
millions of people are interested in
ghosts and a 2013 Harris Poll found that
43% of Americans believe in ghosts
the idea that the dead remain with us in
spirit is an ancient one appearing in
countless stories from the Bible to
Macbeth it even spawned a folklore genre
those stories belief in ghosts is part
of a larger web of related paranormal
beliefs including near-death experiences
life and death and spirit communication
the belief offers many people comfort
who doesn't want to believe that our
beloved but deceased family members
aren't looking out for us or with us in
our times of need now I'm gonna pause
here and give a shout out to Penn
Jillette who said who would really want
to believe that when we die were trapped
in this you know in purgatory playing
parlor tricks on our loved ones like
shaking the lamp I'm here like rocking
the table pay attention to me they did a
funny thing online on the Showtime show
I can't say the name of the show BS
where they showed a bunch of like people
walking around naked and they're like
why would your clothes go with you does
it make sense maybe I don't know all
right let's uh let's reel it more they
say people have tried to or claimed to
communicate with spirits for ages in
Victorian England for example it was
fashionable for upper-crust ladies to
hold séances
in their parlors after tea and crumpets
with friends ghost clubs dedicated
searching for ghostly evidence formed at
prestigious universities including
Cambridge and Oxford and in 1882 the
most prominent organization the Society
for for that psychical psychical
research was established a woman named
Eleanor Sedgwick was an investigator and
later president of that group and could
be considered the original
female Ghostbuster in America during the
late 1800s many psychic mediums claimed
to speak to the dead but were later
exposed as frauds by skeptical
investigators which is Harry Houdini
what a cool dude yeah there's movies
about that yeah
Eleanor Cedric is a cool name Sedgwick
Sidgwick situation situation it wasn't
until it wasn't until recently that
ghost hunting became a widespread
interest around the world much of this
is due to the hit sci-fi cable TV series
ghost hunters now in its second decade
of not finding good effort in the show
spawned dozens of spinouts and imitators
and it's not hard to see why the show is
popular the premise is that anyone can
look for ghosts to original stars were
ordinary guys plumbers in fact who
decided to look for evidence of spirits
their message you don't need to be an
egghead scientist or even have any
training in science or investigation all
you need is some free time a dark place
maybe a few gadgets from electronics
store if you're if you look long enough
any unexplained light or noise noise
might be evidence of ghosts nah I am NOT
a fan of that stuff they basically go in
a dark room and they go oh did you hear
that what the door closed well and then
they run out going are you in here and
then they lay my name if you're in here
have you ever seen this yeah yes and
then they run full-speed out of the room
and the other guys like what happened to
those door door shut and then the door
shut a little bit I don't know like whoa
and there was one I watched where where
the guy was like I'll show you where and
they go back and there's no door it's
like what but there's a there's a door
here and they're like and then like the
music goes like done done during the
like zooms and the guy fake guy's face
and I'm like come on adore didn't
manifest and then like D manifest get
out of here people want to explore
people want to explore those places but
why are guys that's what I'm thinking
when I'm watching them I want answers I
want to go there there's a science the
science and logic of ghosts one
difficulty in scientifically evaluating
ghosts is that a surprisingly wide
variety of phenomena are attributed to
ghosts from a door closing on its own to
missing keys to a cold area in a hallway
to a vision of a dead relative
when sociologists Dennis and Michele
Wasco interviewed ghosts experienced
experiencers for their 2016 book ghostly
encounters the hauntings of everyday
life they found that many participants
were not sure that they had encountered
ghost and remained uncertain that such
phenomena were even possible simply
because they did not see something that
approximated the conventional image of a
ghost instead many of our respondents
were simply convinced that they had
experienced something uncanny something
in explain of an inexplicable
extraordinary mysterious or eerie
thus many people who go on record as
claiming to have any had a ghostly
experience didn't necessarily see
anything that most people would
recognize as a classic a ghost and in
fact they may have had a completely
different they may have had completely
different experiences whose only common
factor is that it could not be readily
explained personal experience is one
thing but scientific evidence is another
matter part of the difficulty in
investigating ghosts is that there is
not one universally agreed-upon
definition of what a ghost is some
believe that their spirits of the Dead
who for whatever reason get lost on
their way to the other side others claim
the ghosts are instead telepathic
entities projected into the world from
our minds I have not heard that
necessarily I guess either but maybe a
poltergeist
I don't know still others create their
own special categories for different
types of ghosts
so just poltergeists okay residual
hauntings intelligent spirits and shadow
people no I don't think that meant
poulter guys I think that meant other
claim that ghosts are instead tell
telepathic entity is projected into the
world from our own minds what I'm
getting from that just yes
essentially yes people tripping on
whether it's on something else or just
that there's a screw loose in their head
that makes them see something I mean
well you know that that makes sense to
me you know the article kind of just
goes on and talks about the logical
inconsistencies like so this here's some
funny things says there are many
contradictions inherent in ideas about
ghosts for example our ghosts material
or not either they can move through
solid objects without disturbing them or
they can slam doors shut and throw
objects across the room well it takes
time you got to learn how to slam and
see in the movies yeah focus like in
beetlejuice right or ghost
yeah ghost let's see what with according
to logic in the laws of physics it's one
or the other
if ghosts are human souls why do they
appear clothed and with presumably
soulless inanimate objects like hats
canes and dresses not to mention the
many reports of ghost trains and
carriages and cars and carriages I
actually have another
ghost theory oh and I didn't tell you
guys about bullying I've got to are you
gonna talk about the first one too yes
all right good you're gonna love this
okay if ghosts are the spirits of those
whose deaths were unavenged why are
there unsolved murders since ghosts are
said to communicate with psychic mediums
and should be able to identify their
killers for the police and so on just
about any claim about ghosts raises
logical reasons to doubt it I agree
ghost hunters use many creative and
dubious methods to detect the spirits
presence often you including psychics
virtually all ghost hunters claim to be
scientific and most give the appearance
because they use high-tech scientific
wittman such as Geiger counters
electromagnetic field detectors ion
detectors infrared cameras and sensitive
microphones yet none of this equipment
has ever been shown to actually detect
ghosts for centuries people believe that
flames turned blue in the presence of
ghosts today few people accept that bit
of lore but it's likely that many of the
signs taken as evidenced by today's
ghost hunters will be seen as just as
wrong and antiquated centuries from now
other researchers claim that the reason
ghosts haven't been proven to exist is
that we simply don't have the right
technology to find or detect the spirit
world but this too can't be correct
either ghosts exist and appear in our
ordinary physical world or they don't if
ghosts exist and can be scientifically
detected or recorded and we should find
hard evidence of that yet we don't if
ghosts exist but cannot be
scientifically detected or recorded then
all the photos videos audio another
recording claiming to be claims to be
evidence of ghosts cannot be ghosts with
so many basic contradictory theories and
so little science brought to bear the
topic it's not surprising that despite
the efforts of thousands of ghost
hunters on television and elsewhere for
decades and a single piece of hard
evidence of ghosts has been found and of
course with the recent development of
ghost apps for smartphones it's easier
than ever to create seemingly spooky
images and share them on social media
making separating fact from fiction even
more difficult - for ghost researchers
and now the moment you've all been
waiting for
I know what ghosts are no you don't you
say yeah I know everything it's just
electrical currents yeah so here's what
I'm thinking about they talk in this
article about the logical
inconsistencies of what a ghost even is
okay is it a physical thing
is it like all light in a photo is it a
flicker you know streak of light in a
photo is it a person with a cane walking
through the house they don't really know
these are a bunch of different things
that may very well may very well be
different things but I started to think
about this various stories told by
people and what is a commonality between
them and what could be a plausible
solution so first what are the common
tropes of hauntings I'm gonna be
selective on this first theory I should
say theory says aha
like not even a hypothesis fun thought
will call that old buildings old it's
always old buildings and I'm thinking
why well what they like to say is that
because someone passed away like the
Lord of the building the more likely it
is someone may have passed in it and now
you're rebuilding likeness that more
than one person right past it and so
then you have these these hotels where
it's like old lady Suzan shows up at
room 13 and they tell you that story and
then people keep seeing like a figure
moving through the halls or whatever but
it's always like translucent or it's a
shadow person in the corner of your eye
and you look and they're gone so here's
what I started thinking a fun thought I
don't actually I'm not saying I believe
it but think about we live in we
experience and I could be totally wrong
about this it's just fun we experience
four dimensions we have three spatial
dimensions and one time dimension we
can't control the time dimension we move
through that so the way explain to
people is try and perceive the time
dimension kind of like if it was space
and if you could actually conceive of it
it would be like driving it as a
passenger in a car yeah you are moving
non-stop or better yet falling
indefinitely if your time is spatial we
are essentially falling indefinitely
because we can't control in any capacity
or just like putting on now imagine that
you live in a really really old building
let's say was built in 1801 fun thought
extra dimensional beings that exist on a
one dimension higher than us in the
fifth dimension or in a fifth dimension
that they can't control so they can
experience time as a spatial dimension
these is way to explain that would be if
a room in a house wasn't just it wasn't
just you know up the stairs into the
left it was up the stairs to the left
and back a couple years
that's how they would actually give
directions like hey where do you keep
the the the the Fanta it's like Oh Fanta
let's uh go downstairs take a right in
the hallway
I'll left just around the corner and
then go back in time about four years
and it's in the fridge right so treating
treating time so so I'll put this way
let's say they're actually dimensional
beings we wouldn't be able to perceive
them because we're moving through time
in one direction that means they can
literally just walk around whatever our
perception is and we wouldn't even be
able to comprehend it but that's why we
see shadow people in the blink of an eye
for a split second yeah because it's the
one point at which they were passing
through and a fraction of a second you
saw it and when you look they're gone
because they moved the other direction
in time which we can do it also it's a
fun idea as to why they're always in old
buildings because it's big the old of
the building the longer the building is
so they just go in there then why do
they slam doors flicker lights and do
parlor tricks cuz they'd like their
space it scurries the people out of the
room yeah
so imagine you're seeing these people
move in like this this predictable
direction and you're you're an extra
dimensional being and your buddies come
over for extra dimensional pizza and
they're like hey where you where do you
keep the like tab and you're like oh tab
man that's that's back in you know
whatever I don't know whatever year when
it was tab a thing is capsule a thing I
don't know coke coke - that was the
thing right that's back in the 90s or
whatever and you're like ah but there's
a bunch of humans it's like go so go
back one month and bang on the door
until they leave but they might take the
tab with them though no no no no oh yeah
they might have restock it and what you
do is you wait till they restock the tab
and then you see the humans path of
where they're going to go because they
can perceive time they say bang on the
door real quick and then the human the
line shifts and goes in a different
direction because now they're panicking
over the weird things happening in their
house and now you can walk in and have
the space all to yourself extra
dimensional beings that is really
interesting and jives perfectly with my
theory which has to do with parallel
universes because I don't know if I
either you guys watched Fringe when that
was a thing I was actually kind of like
that yeah I really liked those let speak
out in there later
so that there's like a parallel universe
that they're operating in so to me that
makes well I got I got a better one I
got a better one what's up
what if our reality and time so so let's
imagine that time isn't necessarily
something we're falling through and
falling through and exists
simultaneously like could be perceived
as space let's say it's more like a
mobius strip of fabric right that moves
around so this was a visualization I saw
of like something a long time ago of
m-theory like 13th meant twelve
dimensional and three or something and
there was like weird dimensional fabrics
that were like moving around and I
started thinking about why is it that we
see an old person from the 1800's with a
cane and a suit because the time we are
on and the time they're on is like a
strip and they just brushed each other
really quickly mm-hmm and so the rooms
are synchronized but the people are not
so it's a rare occurrence where there
are key folds in the space-time okay I
could see so why is it this old building
is haunted well it's because a hundred
years ago the person saw you in the
future when their fabric brushed past
and so they started telling people about
the ghosts I saw strange men wearing
clothes I can't describe it was very you
know very strange and they write it down
100 years later you go there thinking
the same thing the the the different
fabrics of the möbius you know time
strip brush and then you see the guy and
you're like oh it's true I saw the ghost
that would explain why they're wearing
clothes why they're there for the blink
of an eye but it's not necessarily even
mathematically plausible or physically
plausible because I don't know enough
about quantum physics to actually
entertain these ideas see I think this
is all just electricity it's all
electricity we're made of water the
earth has a natural electrical current
going around at every single day called
the tiller current there's ley lines
that they're stronger in some places
than others and we were energy beings
and when when that current goes through
us like it's not like something you can
feel it's not like oh here comes the
telluric current who's you know it's
it's not like that but who knows the
trick to the brain that it does because
it's less during the night
and it what do you mean you're saying
you like hallucinating or what no I mean
I'm I'm saying like a flash it could be
you know just a electrical charge in the
air that like people say you know when
they take a picture and they're like all
of those all the spots there's a ghost
it's like no that's electrical energy in
the air so there's there you know you
know the the Ashbury mmm in Chicago no
it's like it's a cafe in Willow Springs
and Willow Springs Southside you take
the Archer Avenue down to the south side
I could be I could be getting this wrong
but I was there and someone was telling
me that like they've been pushed down
the stairs before like there's a famous
story or something that happened like I
don't know but there's also Resurrection
Mary like Chicago's got a ton of really
famous ghost stories and go and I don't
know how you explain this stuff well how
did you get famous how do you get famous
nowadays now it's the Internet right
yeah so how did you get famous back in
the day you were really famous and for
some specific reason or something crazy
happen to you that like spread around
it's just yeah but it's hard for me to
believe that people are getting pushed
downstairs you know but at the same time
my mom watches the Cisco stuff and
there's this one shot remember the name
of it but there's a an old New York cop
and then there's the psychic and she
goes that there's this her husband comes
into the house clears out the house of
all like family pictures all this stuff
she goes and just does a walkthrough
right and then the cop he goes through
the town
researches the house who got killed
there who was murdered there like
anything that he could find dig up they
don't they don't talk at all I mean this
that's what they say on the show I don't
know if it's true or not but then she
like has a sketch artist come and she's
like alright this is what I saw this and
that and then she gives him all the
stuff in like a sealed envelope and they
sit down with the people and that the
cop opens the stuff and he starts
talking about what he has researched and
of course like 9 out of 10 episodes is
like she's spot-on to all this stuff TV
come on well I mean if it if yeah
exactly I agree it's yeah it doesn't
doesn't make any sense good TV and all I
can think it's like there's got to be
some sort of thing we're not thinking
about and I think it's the electricity
in there
I mean Tesla sent energy out and they
couldn't charge people for it so they
scrapped his experiments but it's like
he was pulling that electricity from the
air you know from from the telluric
current actually that's what I don't
know enough about Tesla to I do know a
few things about his one of his main
experience which is what Edison shut him
down he was like how do we sell this to
people and he was like we can't it's
just in the air it just pulled light
light bulbs like he held the light bulb
in his hand because he sent energy into
the air and it was able to charge the
ball and it's like but I'm pretty sure
we can do that like I've seen what why
don't we do that no no I mean the thing
is it's about efficiency long-term use
like well back then it was about making
people pay for it but the energy is what
my point is the energy is there where
we're on a planet that has a natural
magnetic energy and it's like we don't
really understand what that is you know
yeah well right directing the energy in
a specific direction so that it can be
utilized to charge a closed system or
something it's very different all of
their ghosts all of their ghosts you
know tools or whatever have to do with
electromagnetic energy but they made it
up no I know the reason why they get
fluctuations is because that's what
happens on the planet there is
fluctuations of that kind of energy well
there there actually is a very simple
scientific explanation that's been of
what proposed for what people
experienced ultra low frequency sound
sound that makes sense to me to it
so it's sound frequency it causes people
to feel chills
it makes people what like you know
they've replicated this stuff ultra low
frequency sound you can't detect you
can't hear and they think there's just
some areas that have tectonic activity
that create an ultra low sound frequency
and wouldn't it make sense that some
frequencies vibrate our eyeballs I'm
dead serious
oh I'm not early people people yeah well
those in it a little bit they'll get
stressed they'll feel chills yeah
they'll feel like someone's watching
them yeah exactly cuz they're getting
this weird you know energy sound
vibration is this what what happens to
people who live really close to like
those really big windmills sound maybe
I have no I don't know anyway like I
haven't uh perhaps been near it perhaps
we will never know I will know one day
yeah yeah we'll all learn minutes after
my heart beat that's the last time I
will know thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you